welcome back to the big saturday show as
a sea of men and women in blue pay
tribute to fallen nypd officer jason
rivera anger is mounting among many of
them over the soft on crime policies
responsible for the violence against
police officer rivera's widow also
calling out new york district attorney
bragg for his policies at her husband's
funeral bragg releasing a statement
during the funeral reading in part
violence against police officers will
never be tolerated my office will
vigorously prosecute cases of violence
against police and work to prevent
senseless acts like this from ever
happening again
so that is the statement from the
district attorney but tyrus you look at
the footage of the thousands of police
officers standing shoulder to shoulder
outside for hours yesterday
it felt like a turning point didn't it
it's not just a turning point and i get
really please forgive me i get so
emotional about this because
uh he was 22 years old
this brother was one of the good ones
this is the one that you this is the
police officer that you hope for this is
the one you want that shows up at your
door to protect you and help you and he
was he was gunned down and
they talk about we're going to prosecute
to the fullest extent it's not about the
prosecution it's not about the court
trials it's about protecting our
officers when they're out there giving
them the things that they need having
more officers on the street it just
breaks my heart every time i look at
this kid he was just promoted to a to
first grade detective you know he's 22
years old this he was a star
and he's gone and the best you can come
up with is we're going to prosecute to
the fullest of our what about we're
going to put more police on the street
we're going to protect our officers
we're going to we're going to get things
going we're going to make when you do
things against police officers there is
no bail you know there is
we just not it's it's so hard to even
put into words sometimes i'm really
every time i look at this young man's
face my eyes water up because
we always want to talk about the bad
ones and we always want to just go after
them and talk about all police are bad
he
his young life was snatched away and it
just breaks my heart and you never
you're not hearing the things that you
need to be hearing from from officials
anymore it's just it's it's
heartbreaking it's it is absolutely
heartbreaking and
um the
his father jason rivera's father a
family friend said that he's right now a
broken man in complete disbelief and one
of his um childhood friends said that he
was always smiling like you said truly
one of the good guys and described him
as the baby brother of the block so it
seems like a tight-knit community that
he lived in and every single one of
their lives will forever be changed the
person whose life may be changed the
most in all of this is his wife they
just got married in october and emily i
don't think that what she said at the
funeral can be aired enough take a
listen to her really powerful statement
standing up to power talking directly to
the district attorney watch this
the system continues to fail us we are
not safe anymore
not even the members of the service
i know you were tired of these laws
especially the ones from the new d.a
and one of the crimes emily that d.a
braggs initially said he wasn't going to
prosecute was resisting arrest now he
because the spotlight is on him is sort
of softening his stance but do you trust
that
no i don't carly and i had the honor of
standing in that crowd there on fifth
avenue in solidarity and showing my
support for jason rivera officer jason
rivera as well as the thousands of law
enforcement that had turned up to show
support for him and his family and all
of us right representing every american
that wished that they could be there i
was there and so i listened to her
eulogy on the loudspeakers outside and
everyone was crying we were all crying
on the streets and we all started
clapping in the church and outside when
she said d.a bragg i hope you are
listening to me and for him to say we're
doing all we can to work to prevent
senseless acts like this from happening
again i don't know what that means
because what that takes is preventing
recidivism what that takes is not
reclassifying crimes from felonies to
misdemeanors to misdemeanors so that you
can keep these guys in jail it means it
means not letting them out on these
notions of bail reform that have real
effects we know there's a 16 year old
right now loose on the streets who was
charged with shooting a cop thank god it
wasn't fatal but he made his own bail
and he's out and that's under d.a
bragg's watch so i think to your point
we absolutely cannot trust that there
will be follow through but also we seem
to be speaking a different language
because from where i sit it takes a lot
more from our elected officials and
appointed officials to support law
enforcement to get safety and order back
on our streets and it begins with him i
know the mayor's trying but i also have
to point out you guys that in the last
year alone we know that that 60
skyrocket of officers that have been
killed in the line of duty due to
felonious acts right but the most
disturbing category within that was
ambushes unprovoked and premeditated
ambushes that category spiked 300
percent and officer rivera and officer
amora were included in that on friday
night and this is the kind of commentary
that leads to that so i expect more and
better because while we were standing
outside and everyone was mourning and
grieving i heard sirens in the other
part of the city and i thought to myself
you know what well all these guys are
showing up
to support officer rivera and his legacy
and his death guys are also out there
protecting the chickens
right for 24 hours so they're shouting
out for us we need people to show up for
that and you know i'm so glad that you
said that we expect more and better
because um lee zeldin he's running for
governor he's a new york gubernatorial
candidate and here he is on what needs
to be done
to stop this rising crime here are some
of the ideas he laid out watch this
we need to repeal castle spell we need
to support law enforcement more not less
pass a law enforcement bill of rights
repeal a new bill that they signed
called less is more they're releasing
people early from prison we need to pass
a law enforcement bill of rights
recognize their inherent right of
self-defense make sure they have all the
tools and resources they need to do
their job safely and effectively protect
qualified immunity and so much more
charlie
you know it's really great that the d.a
is now coming out and reversing his
position on violence against police
officers uh but the fact that he had to
that alone is absolutely astonishing
and you know the direct line that you
can tie between the rhetoric of so many
democrats over the last couple of years
and the senseless acts of violence in
these cities in particular against
police officers
those things can be turned directly into
political ads and they will be and these
democrat politicians will be held
accountable
absolutely right and all three of you
made such great points hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else